all'alba della dell'agricoltura umana
circa 10 mila anni fa
sull'intera superficie terrestre il
genere umano compreso il suo bestiame e
agli animali domestici contavano per
circa lo 0,1 per cento dell'intera
biomassa dei vertebrati oggi contano per
il 98 per cento dal 1950 ad oggi abbiamo
modificato la terra più di quanto noi
avessimo fatto nei precedenti 10 mila
anni
e questo nonostante il fatto che le
nostre cognitivi abilità cognitive di
base pensiero memoria ragionamento
causale non siano distinguibili da
quelle degli altri primati
però noi umani abbiamo un'abilità
particolare quella dell'intenzionalità
condivisa e attraverso l'intenzionalità
condivisa siamo riusciti a creare un
tipo di artefatti che sono profondamente
diversi da quelli creati dalle altre
specie viventi
uno di questi artefatti e nel più uno
dei più recenti e proprio alla base di
questa eccezionale esplosione che si è
avuta negli ultimi sessant'anni ed e il
calcolo automatico mediato dalle
correnti deboli e otto anni fa
scene touring è riuscita in un'impresa
che non era riuscito a nessun altro
prima con breve ma fortunato articolo di
solo tre pagine su communication ix e xi
m è riuscito a sensibilizzare non solo
la comunità accademica ma anche politici
educatori per far inserire il pensiero
computazionale nell'agenda
dell'alfabetizzazione dei cittadini del
terzo millennio
purtroppo in molti casi in questo
tentativo di promuovere i processi di
alfabetizzazione e soprattutto nei
bambini più piccoli si confina alla
programmazione perdendo moltissimo di
quello che
invece la natura del calcolo automatico
della computer science e vorrebbe
veramente la pena conoscere qualcosa di
più te sulla natura degli artefatti per
poter permettere di avere delle azioni
educative che siano un pochettino più
efficaci e non ripetere gli errori che
abbiamo compiuto in passato
come per esempio nell'insegnamento della
matematica che spesso viene descritta
dai bambini come quella disciplina in
cui la maestra ci hai problemi e noi
dobbiamo risolvere se guardiamo a quello
che la psicologia ci dice a riguardo
alla natura degli artefatti e
soprattutto al percorso tracciato da
lefkofsky e of all di lee hancock e
michael cosa noi possiamo almeno
catturare una delle peculiarità degli
strumenti umani la loro natura duale il
fatto che loro siano contemporaneamente
materiali e concettuali ma io non vi
parlerò degli studi di questi studiosi
ma vi racconterò una storia una storia
che è risultata incredibile anche la
stessa studiosa che ne ha tessuto la
trama tennis c'è ma basterà venisse ma
abbasserà e un'archeologa e ci ha
raccontato questa storia di come è nata
la scrittura di come attraverso la
scoperta
l'invenzione del calcolo si è venuta
fuori la scrittura
lei era interessato essenzialmente a gli
artefatti d'argilla nell epoca
preistorica e quando arrivò in iraq si
trovò davanti una situazione incredibile
trovo una quantità enorme di questi
piccoli gettoni d'argilla distribuiti in
tutto il medioriente e su un periodo che
andava dalle 8000 avanti cristo fino al
2500 avanti cristo
questi token fanno la loro apparizione
proprio in coincidenza con l'agricoltura
con il fatto che i sumeri iniziano a
coltivare il grano e il fatto che
producono grano li porta anche a dover
inventare dei metodi per archiviare il
fatto che per devono archiviare questo
grado li porta anche alla necessità di
trovare dei mezzi per amministrare
questo bene comune fra di loro e loro si
affidano appunto a questi token a questi
settori d'argilla
vanno a rappresentare contemporaneamente
quantità e qualità
un cono rappresentava una quantità
piccola di cereali o una sfera
rappresentava una grande quantità di
cereali e un cilindro ad esempio
rappresentava un animale nel giro di 2
mila anni
questi token erano diffusi ormai
dappertutto nel medio oriente e
servivano appunto per fare questa
rendicontazione amministrazione dei beni
ma intorno al 5 mila avanti cristo
iniziano ad apparire delle sfere
d'argilla dentro il quale sono messi
questi token e queste sfere sono create
per poter permettere non più soltanto
l'amministrazione dei beni per la
redistribuzione bensì il commercio i
contenuti all'interno di una sfera vanno
a rappresentare uno scambio già eseguito
o una transazione promessa però queste
storie hanno un nord e svantaggio il
fatto che una volta sigillate anche se
fatte di argilla non è più possibile
vedere quello che c'è dentro e quindi
c'è bisogno di romperle per poter
guardare e vedere se ci sono aspetti
controversi e così a qualcuno venne
l'idea di andare a imprimere i token
sulla strada dell'argilla quando questa
era ancora morbida in modo tale da poter
vedere attraverso quelle impressioni
quali era il contenuto e questo sistema
funzionano abbastanza andò avanti per
tanto tempo fino a che non iniziarono a
creare molti nuovi tipi di beni come i
tessuti corte e quant'altro e a questo
punto i token diventarono complessi non
c'erano più soltanto delle forme ma
queste forme venivano uccise e questo
portò al fatto che non era più possibile
andare a imprimere i token sulla
superficie della bolla per poter creare
delle figure decifra pts erano
indecifrabili
e così ci si mosse verso la prima forma
di protoscar i tour a il fatto che
appaiono queste prime bolle prime
tavolette in cui le impressioni si
affiancano alle incisioni per poi
passare abbastanza rapidamente a le
tavolette di argilla dove le incisioni
costituiscono la gran parte della
rappresentazione
ora perché vi racconto questa storia
perché vorrei di vip oneste per un
attimo a questa domanda che cosa
rappresentano queste incisioni sulla
tavoletta sicuramente rappresentano
delle quantità di beni rappresentano uno
scambio che è stato promesso oppure uno
scambio che è stato già effettuato ma
questo in qualche modo è banale in
qualche modo si annulla questo processo
evolutivo quello che realmente
rappresentano questi segni sono il
processo di differenziazione fra gli
elementi sono il processo di
immagazzinamento processo di recupero il
processo di confronto rappresentano in
realtà le operazioni che noi dobbiamo
compiere sul sistema di rappresentazione
non la relazione tra rappresentante è
rappresentato il vero potere delle
rappresentazioni astratte concili nel
fatto che loro ci raccontano le azioni
che noi vogliamo compiere attraverso
quel tipo di strumento e questo fatto
questo fatto che le azioni svolgono un
ruolo fondamentale in realtà è
rintracciabile anche sin dal primo
momento che sono stati creati token
perché questi sono stati creati sin
dall'inizio per essere differenziati fra
di loro essere facilmente riproducibili
essere aggregabili confrontabili ancora
una volta ci troviamo davanti alla
situazione in cui quello che è veramente
rappresentato sono le operazioni da
compiere e chi si accorse per primo ebbe
la prima intuizione che e del ruolo
ontologico che svolgono le azione nelle
costruzioni astratte furyk ten stein
quando si accorse appunto che il
significato delle parole non sta nelle
parole ma sta negli usi che noi
aggiungiamo alle parole le parole quelle
che io sto dicendo sono soltanto dei
richiami di attenzione il loro
significato sta nel nostro territorio
comune e che per questo proprio
raccontato una storia per far vaccinare
le azioni che erano necessarie per poter
fare questi passaggi ora
è bene capire che il processo di
astrazione non è un processo in cui noi
cerchiamo di agganciare dei simboli a
dalla realtà concrete questo è banale lo
possono fare qualunque degli altri
primati che vivono con noi sulla terra
quello che invece è fondamentale nel
processo di astrazione e quello di
incorporare le nostre azioni nell'arte
fatto per poter permettere delle azioni
che prima non erano eseguibili e
l'astrazione crea di fatto uno stato di
realtà concettuale e materiale sulla
quale noi possiamo successivamente agire
separare in generale qualunque forma di
conoscenza dalla parte concettuale da
quella materiale è un orrore ontologico
gravissimo noi l'abbiamo ci ha commesso
tantissime volte e pensare ancora oggi
per di separare nel pensiero
computazionale le forme di energia che
noi reclutiamo amministriamo e per lo
meno ingenuo e sicuramente
pedagogicamente non efficace la
stabilizzazione del pensiero
computazionale dovrebbe partire proprio
dal reclutamento delle energie quelle
che noi oggi utilizziamo per la
computazione domani non utilizzeremo
delle altre accordo quindi partire da
questi piccoli circuiti elettrici ed è
proprio quello che noi stiamo cercando
di fare partendo capitalizzando
un'esperienza importantissima quella
fatta all'esploratore in uno di san
francisco nel team che l'ing studio dove
attraverso la collaborazione come detto
ackermann
stiamo immaginando un nuovo modo di
poter permettere di passare da piccoli
circuiti elettrici a al comportamento
degli oggetti attraverso piccoli
microcontrollori quello che vi
presenterò e un brevissimo video un
prodotto rapidamente in questi giorni di
una sperimentazione che è in atto presto
i nostri laboratori all'università e si
inizia proprio con far percepire ai
bambini la corrente far sentire la
corrente e fargli comprendere che la
corrente a un verso e sia attraverso i
loro effetti sui led sia sugli effetti
sui motori
poi si attaccano a questi nei motori
delle strutture molto semplici con un
pennarello magari le screening machine
dell'expo l'oratorio in seguito si
attaccano due motori sulla stessa spree
bling machine in modo tale da poter
permettere di programmare il loro
comportamento e differenziarlo e infine
introduciamo un piccolo amico
controllore che controlliamo attraverso
disegni grafici gestiamo l'energia che
andiamo a dare ai motori oppure mettiamo
in relazione degli ingressi con delle
uscite semplicemente facendo le
scegliere sull'applicazione che stiamo
sperimentando nel potesse finisce quindi
questa ambiente che stiamo realizzando
che stiamo sperimentando esplorando di
fatto si appoggia su dei linguaggi ormai
consolidati ma semplifica moltissimo
tutto quanto gli aspetti sintattici per
focalizzarci sugli aspetti semantici
dell'interazione per poter permettere ai
bambini di poter comprendere come
amministrare queste energie per produrre
dei comportamenti negli oggetti del
mondo vede infatti questo diciamo il
nostro obiettivo fondamentale quello di
pensare in che modo prima di insegnare
ai bambini a programmare il
comportamento dei pixel sullo schermo
quello di insegnare a programmare il
comportamento degli oggetti intorno a
noi perché questo non soltanto è molto
più intrigante e coinvolgente per i
bambini ma soprattutto permette di
evitare ancora una volta l'errore di
separare le nostre conoscenze
concettuali da quelle materiali
grazie